tenemos la compañía abc de cotizando a
50 dólares y una lista del diagrama de
pelos para una opción de venta precio de
ejercicio de 50 dólares tratada a 10
dólares un cigarrillo trajo dos tipos de
diagramas al primer tipo sólo le importa
llevar el valor de la opción inspiración
y esto es lo que tiendes a ver en los
ambientes académicos en escuelas de
negocios el segundo tipo nos muestra un
dibujo de pérdidas y ganancias basado en
la posición de la opción este incorpora
el precio que pagaste por la opción es
más común ver está en la práctica
entonces tienes una opción de venta
recuerda que ese es el derecho de vender
de vender a 50 dólares si el valor
digamos que al vencimiento se negocia en
cero pues la empresa está declarada en
bancarrota es ahora sin valor entonces
cuál es el valor de la opción de venta
bueno ahora podrías ir al mercado y
comprarla por monedas de un centavo es
más comprarlo por casi cero dólares y
después ejercer tu opción de venta y
podrías venderla por cien
cuenta dólares por lo que
definitivamente ejerciendo las áreas
demasiado dinero esto es el valor del
subyacente para ser comprado está en
cero y la opción de venta ahora valdría
50 dólares
tú puedes comprar por 0 y venderlo a 50
dólares del precio de subyacente es de
10 dólares todavía es posible comprar
por 10 dólares y después llegar y si
tienes la opción ejercerla y venderla en
50 dólares entonces habrás ganado 40
dólares de la opción o viceversa el
valor de las opciones se vuelve menos y
el valor de la acción se vuelve más y
más hasta obtener 50 50 y 50 dólares a
50 dólares realmente no te importa pues
tienes el derecho de vender algo a 50
dólares cuando tú lo compraste en 50
dólares así que el valor de la opción de
venta empieza en 50 porque tienes el
derecho de vender algo sin valor en 50
dólares y la acción se declara en
quiebra y en 50 dólares la opción se
convierte en realmente nada no tiene más
valor si la opción sube por encima de
cualquier cosa
hay que deducir el valor que pasa si el
precio está en 100 dólares algo como eso
no nos conviene ejerce pues por qué
querrías ejercer la opción de vender
algo que a ti te costó en el mercado 100
dólares y venderlo en 50 similares en el
caso de pérdidas y ganancias si la
opción no vale nada se podría comprar
por nada y después si tienes la opción
de venta venderla por 50 dólares tenemos
que incorporar el pago de 10 dólares que
existe por entrar el contrato tenemos
que el valor es de 50 dólares menos los
10 dólares por lo que al final
tendríamos 40 dólares y estas serán las
opciones o posibles formas de ejercer la
opción hasta llegar a 50 pero 50 dólares
antes decir que es inútil hay que
recordar que en el valor de 50 dólares
tendrás que hacer la opción pero pagaste
10 dólares por esto por lo que no
ejercerán pues pagaste 10 dólares
entonces tendrás que tomar 10 dólares de
pérdida y la opción empezará a
convertirse en cada vez menos hasta aquí
en el punto en que no hay esas que
tomaste pérdida de pagar por la opción
no ejercida
y de ahí en adelante tomaras la pérdida
de 10 dólares